what's in your socks these are
and a rabbit just one rabbit
[Music]
so today traditionally you have to have
access to a hospital and all the
equipment inside of it to get really
accurate diagnostic tests done for many
diseases and at Mammoth were really
leveraging CRISPR and specifically
CRISPR Diagnostics to democratize access
to that type of molecular information
myself and one of my co-founders
actually Terron she we had both were
finishing up our PhDs and we both saw
that there's so much activity especially
a place like Stanford commercializing
various technologies out of the lab and
especially in areas like therapeutics
the machine learning there's just maybe
a new startup every day it seems but in
other areas like diagnostic that there
seemed to be a lot less activity and we
were really kind of curious about why
that was the case and we saw that really
a lot of the same technologies have been
used for many decades now so we decided
that there's got to be a better way and
maybe we don't even know what it is at
that time but that better way has to be
out there hidden locked up maybe
somewhere maybe it's yet to be
discovered
after we founded the company shortly
thereafter - at the time graduate
students Janice Chen and Lucas
Harrington had made these really big
advances in CRISPR Diagnostics in the
moment we saw these papers we knew that
this was the way that Diagnostics was
going to go in the future so we
immediately reached out to them Jennifer
about forming a team and they were very
entrepreneurial and very interested and
totally shared our vision of
democratizing Diagnostics so in the end
it was a complete no-brainer for us all
to team up and to form mammoth
Biosciences the most important trait for
an entrepreneur is easily grit I mean it
goes along with all these ideas around
perseverance and really just not taking
no for an answer as long as you believe
in the final goal on the one hand I'm
very lucky that I've grown up in an
environment where I have that
opportunity and I definitely don't take
that for granted because not everyone
even has the opportunity to become an
entrepreneur maybe they have to worry
about other things and I think as a
society we should definitely do more so
that people from ebony background can
really take risks and take the many
extreme risks you need to take to really
be an entrepreneur
if you believe in something you
shouldn't give up because there's gonna
be so many times along the way that it
seems like it's not gonna work and it's
really easy to get disillusioned but if
you believe in the dream and you believe
in what you're doing then you have to
persevere through
[Music]
you